hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to civilization 6 now I'm
not going to claim to be an expert in
the civilization games in fact I'm
probably very bad so if you came here
for expert gameplay i am i apologizing
civilization like i do i've been a fan
of it since about civilization 3 i
thoroughly enjoy it because III don't
know what it is about it captures that
essence of commanding the entire world
in the the feeling of exploration is
really cool and i it appeals to me in a
grandstand but i just don't have the
patience to play like the super long
games or like keep a marathon get really
good at the game so what i'm gonna play
this i'm gonna play it just to have some
fun i'm not gonna do a long series on it
but I am just gonna have some fun this
game just came out either today or
yesterday or whenever so I'm just gonna
play a brand new game no I'm gonna
create a custom game thank you very much
I'm gonna pick my leader thank you very
much Catherine de Medici Cleopatra
typical Gandhi [ __ ] I got dead Teddy
Roosevelt hell yeah alright game
difficulty you know I'm gonna set a high
standard for myself if I call myself the
king of a lot of things I'm definitely
gonna be a king here alright so I'm
gonna do standard we're not gonna get
very far alright whatever I'm just gonna
do shuffle because I can't do it now
we're gonna do small because I don't
have the patience to explore a giant
desolate wasteland
so come on Teddy we're gonna do this
first stirrings of life beneath water oh
yeah to the great beasts of the Stone
Age Oh
- man taking his first upright steps you
have come far yes I have now begins your
greatest quest from this early cradle of
civilization on towards the Stars let
Sean Bean and so it is upon your broad
shoulders Theodore Roosevelt to charge
forth and lead your people on their
great adventure use your military might
to give the peoples of your homeland the
square deal they so desperately deserve
surely you will raise America into the
limelight and attract visitors from
across the oceans just to see your lungs
Bali for you mr. president
bully bully indeed bully for Sean Bean
bully for world domination a square deal
for America and America alone [ __ ] all
those other guys and Gandhi especially
[ __ ] that guy okay so apparently we're
gonna be a bit more militaristic as your
personal advisor I am qualified to
assist you in all matters related to
ruling our civilization I'm at your
service
oh oh you think I don't know how to play
the answer is probably that I do not but
I'm not gonna pay any attention to you
I'm new to this one well I ain't much
for being picky how about we settle
right on here do the found a city thing
hell yeah
oh no we can't see all right so we got
warriors
we got Washington nothing being produced
we need to do something about that I am
gonna do a thing
ah man man Teddy Roosevelt ain't no he
ain't no astrologer
he's animal husbandry Oh hundred percent
that's so Teddy oh hell yeah all right
we're doing that
code of laws I don't know do we have any
laws we a total anarchy here is
everything gonna die horribly the answer
is yes except for us we're gonna survive
because nothing can kill the bull moose
president all right what are we doing ah
we need to build a monument to my
greatness but we do need a builder but
we don't have a builder maybe we can get
a builder now you know what I know I'm
great I know I'm amazing I know
everything about that but other people
don't know how great I am I need to
build a monument and that's gonna be the
first thing that we build because I'm
amazing and everyone should know about
it are you dick hole mcdu ger you go
over there oh yes oh yes
what'd you find you found water and a
[ __ ] frozen plain good job and rice
fields cool and cows
we're gonna get outta husbandry and get
over there anyway next turn we're done
air we did it we're good who else is
here someone's scattering around in the
darkness by the Krakens and the whatever
the hell that is
and then that thing nothing over here
except more horrors all right I guess go
this way
oh no did I just aw - Peninsula ah I
went the wrong way cuz I'm an idiot
oh wait there's Jade over there holy
[ __ ] there's a lot of resources over
here seems like seems like Washington
was founded in in in East Asia I'm not
sure why or how but I'm okay with it
but aboot well I guess we can go back
there's nothing over there how about a
habit a habit how about a charge we got
nothing to do for a long time so you
just got to keep marching you dick
what's over here
whoo that's more like it a town to
ransack hell yes it was si the appeal is
breathtaking
oh yeah oh I want that oh we're gonna
make a city there oh hell yes we are all
right we're gonna go visit you don't
mind our axes and our maces their
friendliness axes we're gonna have a
wait why am i yeah why am I doing this
you guys have been like you don't know
how to play me the answer is yes I do
not hello reconnaissance flight Scouts
are unique in that they can gain
experience by exploring and discovering
parts of the world that's nice is that
new to save six cuz I can't quite
remember my brother is actually a much
bigger fan of this game than I am but
it's cool though
because it's just like you know me and
my own is my thing and I'm this and
everyone else can go die anyway we got
animal husbandry so we got a running
I've animal husbandry we'll get that now
we're apparently got a scout so where
you gonna go you go venture this way go
over there ish good job another town
okay cancel your previous orders and do
this thing okay how do I cancel previous
orders I think I got it
right so you're gonna go your knowledge
of masonry hidden technical secret yay
we killed them and stole their knowledge
as Teddy would have wanted oh I love it
I love the ambience of it I love the
patience of it I love like I don't have
the patience to play really long games
but it's something about late it's so
appealing just to have a game and it be
this thing where you just sit and you
enjoy the environment and let it play
out around you isn't that right teddy
Theodore Roosevelt was very big into
preserving the natural resources of
America you can thank a lot of the parks
that we have here in America North
America the United States of America
whatever you want to call it to Teddy
Roosevelt who was very big into all that
stuff he loved nature and that's why he
was such a [ __ ] badass because he was
a badass that's all he was he wrestled
bears he ate rocks he was super super
hardcore like that I can't remember if
he was in Civ five I don't think so
right anyway we're down here everybody's
done I'm good time being done all right
what are we doing who the [ __ ] are you
you wanna you wanna you wanna you wanna
you want a tussle huh buddy boo hey who
are you
hi how are you doing nice on that
charming grassland mines you know just
average you got the charming one I don't
know why oh I don't wanna
Takia says major victory I mean who is
that
is anybody how kill him take some of
this yeah keep the dogs out of this is
just between you and me oh gosh well
that didn't work I didn't do nothin
little ooh all right where we going here
I don't know what we got I don't know
what we got our monument is not built
yet what I don't know what we got that
must be barbarians
yeah it's barbaric hey you stay out my
city policies in our government can be a
great benefit whoo
our people await your decree sure how do
I do that
ah [ __ ] I am fond of pigs dogs look up
to us cats look down on us pigs treat is
as equals well that's an interesting
slogan why not a slogan from 20 it is
not wisdom but authority that makes a
law nice
thanks Jon bean again your voice is
soothing alright so we need to change
policies what shall we do discipline huh
the best defense is beating the [ __ ] out
of everybody around you okay we need no
God King I could be a God king amongst
mere mortals God markiplier God of the
squirrels God of five nights if friend
at sounds terrible I'll try urban
planning cuz that sounds better and I
need to produce things yeah we're good
except we got you know freakin
barbarians over here can you beat the
[ __ ] out of them already hit him harder
Adam God use something more than a stick
well I'm not gonna be able to get back
with these guys so oh well oh hi
how's it going hey oh that's a charming
wooden grassland with a river I'm gonna
take that kill you steal all of your
stuff you all remember it cuz you're
dead and then take your city for my own
and maybe even found a city there
because I am just that cool alright fine
we need to research something else ah
Bob
boo boo bah bah bah bah ooh we could get
the Rough Riders oh we love horseback
riding ah so good not very useful long
run but now I want horses horsies Oh
civic ooh foreign trade craftsmanship
boo boo boo boo boo boo trade routes we
need those we need a lot of those all
right we're down here everybody done
we're good
everybody good y'all good oh yeah you
better stay away I'm still gonna beat
the [ __ ] out of you
although it'd be tactically bad to go
over there because then they're good the
Turkish and I don't think it's gonna be
a good or do so we gonna I'm just gonna
I'm gonna tacky and like later what one
later I'm gonna try to go there and
you're gonna you're gonna get it you're
gonna get it have whiskey oh [ __ ] dude
Oh God
yeah don't hurt the dog please okay we
did it whoo we killed a guy all right
we're off to a great start in this
empire of ours he was just a scout he
wasn't doing nothing and we killed him
great right anyway that Monument done
yet three more turns good god murder
murder okay get back to exploring you
douche go over there
all right you it says major victory but
I don't believe that I don't think they
can attack us from there but maybe we
can maybe we can get a thing maybe we
can do a thing say it says I might win
cuz I got a +5 against barbarians it's a
stalemate god damn it
okay so attacking from this position is
not good but if I'm gonna die I could
die from a breathtaking Vista I mean
that sounds pretty good
river defense oh yeah that's what it is
cuz they're there defending from the
river so if I'm there so if I have if I
cross the river first and then attack
I'd have a better advantage but I take a
hit before I get there
oh don't look good I'll take the hit I
think I can hit them too if they do
attack me I don't know if they will I'm
gonna do this cuz it seems like better
option
all right you go buddy oh you found crab
you like craft a lot craft okay
major victory well let's see about that
how those key have a bam-bam-bam
yeah even though we look like the
barbarians here with our young kilts and
stone weapons and looking like
barbarians and you guys look rather
civilized and broad-chested but you know
I'm gonna assume that you're the bad guy
here we are all we built a monument ah
yes the Roosevelt monument a bit stout
but still noble we need a settler I'm
gonna take your [ __ ] because at what
from what I see oh it's only charming
then it was breathtaking over there why
do I even want your [ __ ] maybe I'll just
found a city next to you and you can go
eat a dick right what do we got here
purchased I'll I don't have the goal for
that I only got something with you gold
purchase an item with gold I can't
afford those alright we're building the
settler or just a tile maybe 50 gold I
don't want that I mean I got enough food
I mean the city's obviously growing if
you didn't know I'm assuming you guys
all have a base knowledge of
civilization like you you establish your
base and then it grows based on the
tiles around you better they'd be food
production this place is awfully good
because it does offer more food but I
kind of want that forest because it
offers production which is something
that I do need two of them cuz I want to
be able to build things faster I mean
eventually as your city expands it's
gonna do this anyway but if you spend
your gold you might get an advantage
early on so I'm gonna try it I don't
know if it's gonna be worth it but I'll
be able to complete this settler rule
more quickly alright next you like a
craft good job on the craft bananers Wow
we're stranded there's nobody here where
is the [ __ ] we got to get boats to get
out I shouldn't have picked Rando maybe
maybe that's like a land bridge over
there that's gonna connect me to the
other things can you still beat the [ __ ]
out of those guys what are you tired
[ __ ] you gonna needs orders I know unit
needs orders ok you need to go all the
way over here and then you need to beat
the [ __ ] out of them I said beat the
[ __ ] not fall over and die ok it's
one of them left you're gonna fall over
and die too one of them huh oh [ __ ]
hello we're deaf oh you made that you
birth that okay yeah Adam have let her
Berlin I think I missed a turn there
like an idiot mine now this is mine
thank you all right cool we learned out
a foreign trade we learned out to be
civil and trade with people after we
murdered all of you that's the positive
aspect of trade I suppose the world gets
stirred up together nice I need to find
other people to be able to do that ah
naval units who we do need naval I'm
gonna assume that we're gonna be good
about this we're gonna get naval stuff
and I like trading and we only have one
city so plus one isn't doing us a whole
lot of good
haha hell yeah we're so set we're the
greatest we're gonna choose a civic what
is that
mysticism Oh Teddy Roosevelt wants an
empire give me my empire give me all of
my Empire all right you guys can you
attack that guy can you still see you're
still going okay how about a habit a
habit a habit a habit come on Poochie
we're gonna get it we discovered a
continent when did we discover a new
continent Oh God
oh no we got scoops that scoot is
looking at us very dirty like all right
bar bows get back to home base because
you need to defend it even though you're
very slow oh I'm so gonna have a base
over there by all the crafts
oh yeah is it charming is it charming
tell me it's charming
oh it's breathtaking oh hell yeah oh god
yeah oh this is only charming man if I
had just gone one over I would have had
that but whatever it's fine all right
you getting back you're getting back
blah blah blah I'm done dude do more
turns get more quicker whoo-hoo what
happened
hey we level up oh yeah we had
population growth hell yeah
hell yeah a unit available for promotion
really ooh
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba-ba how do I
promote you you are a little [ __ ] do I
promote you okay either I'm dumb and I
don't understand this or I'm not getting
it which I think oh we're trapped
goddamn it let me let me look up isn't
there like a help yeah okay oh it wasn't
you that was available for the promotion
it was the other guy stop feeling all
the credit you dick Portis yeah we're
gonna battlecry charge and charge again
once more unto the breach my friends but
we are [ __ ] and also water locked
until we decide to stop being such a
douche so I'm assuming we're on the
southern edge because it looks like
we're on the southern edge of the map
it's fast you're a ranger you're a rough
ridin Ranger boo
you know you automate exploration not
that there's much left to explore but
you just go for it okay hello where did
you come from
oh hey where are you all coming from you
being dropped off by a boat somewhere ah
stalemate yeah just you know just run
away quickly you're a coward you already
killed you don't want to kill again you
you wash your hands clean of all the
blood of your enemies I understand
oh hello what the [ __ ] happened what the
[ __ ] oh god I was like I saw the red I
was like holy [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] thought we died alright
that's fine though okay so it's got
recommended spots over here which is
kind of where I was I'm gonna put in and
also over there which pretty sure wait
isn't this seafaring - just because I'm
by a river isn't that how that goes I
have no idea they want the graph oh I
want all that crap alright final I'll do
the guide off I'll get the cras later
hope that Scout doesn't call my cell or
any problems we need goddamnit we can't
build nothing we can't build dick
I need a builder I gotta have a builder
I don't know why it doesn't want me to
have a builder habit but I'm turning on
quick movement because it's taking too
long
alright you
what would happen minor victory now come
back over here whoa whoa hey hey whoa
whoa whoa we all right that's speedy I
like it right Scout you uh automate or
whatever you you're not where you're
supposed to be are you are you why did
the change oh I want that craft want on
that Chris I'm gonna go over here what
there we go Zippity zappity Bop it was
luxuries like air conditioning that
brought down the Roman Empire with air
conditioning their windows were short
they couldn't hear the barbarians coming
that doesn't make any sense I'm gonna
assume you're being sarcastic all right
what do we get ooh colonization me likey
me need colonization hell yeah oh yeah
right is this a good place for a city no
I said I was gonna be on top of the
barbarians corpses so I really feel like
I wouldn't be up to my word if Idol
didn't do that I'd be kind of a liar I
don't want that all right where are we
headed we got early Emperor Empire games
and recreation hell yeah
political philosophy oh so many things
ah no drama craftsmanship I love to
build stuff building stuff is awesome
it's like the coolest crap I want crafts
how to get sailing why are we stuck on
horseback riding
god damn it is why I need a builder our
unit sees orders Oh our Burien horseman
where are these barbarians come back
come come back home come home whose zip
zip zop zu buddy bop I want to be
stuffed in the face with a spear do you
all right just go back oh I forgot only
one can be fortified that's right that's
right
okay you go out of there you go you will
[ __ ] are you saddle their greatest city
gaining the city on the coast has given
your civilization insight into
navigating the ways your knowledge of
sailing has advanced considerably yay
can we switch I think I can switch right
oh hell yeah I can switch yeah
yes god that's a lot of [ __ ] that you
need well I don't have time to do any of
that so can i buy tiles oh yes I can oh
yes if I'm gonna get you craft this
sounds gonna grow really quickly the
only thing it doesn't have is a lot of
production but we can build improvements
once we actually have a builder get this
and this and we are good that's gonna be
good enough for me
the traitor all right you focus on the
train or it'll get better over time I'll
get better you just gotta let it be
better and then you're gonna get better
don't worry about it are you fortified
there because there's nothing left to
explore you go next turn Oh shitty dicks
okay what about would be minor victory
oh they are riding horseback and I
didn't good any other enemies all right
you know what I'm gonna be over here
this guy's also gonna help out because I
can't have you doing things that's gonna
be a major defeat well I'm just gonna
fortify there you're gonna fortify there
alright next turn don't go to my new
city ah there we go good thing got
fortified hey take my stick yeah you
thought that hurt when that horse
trampled my face yeah [ __ ] you oh god
I'm almost dead ah jeez okay you you you
just you you take a knee take a knee
good buddy alright you're gonna get a
victory there like it I like it have it
about about boom but about Oh what have
you are down but the horsies okay bye or
Z oh no you're gonna get oh you're gonna
get dead I'm sorry so long as my settled
Stowe hey woah
we're away whoa whoa what say what's
this all about here you just don't do
that
ow my face all right can you
Scouty boo can you finish him off Oh God
well that's not good oh oh oh no oh no
when did this happen
kepta bouzouki get kill him he's dead
right okay good he's dead jeez ohms I
need to get more enemies
ooh bronze working hey nice all right
cool we got that benefit so we need more
when we need her warriors
oddly enough so I'm just gonna build
warriors I don't have enough gold to buy
one but we're definitely gonna do
something about this all right you guys
get builder we can build a farm here
farm okay get to work on that you guys
go back here whoa
all right so you are in trouble so go to
Charleston I can't name it man the
barbarians are really barbaric oh my god
don't kill my builders they took so long
to build that's not good
you guys go back to Washington and Fort
de fer you are pretty much boned that's
as far as I know maybe you just don't
build a farm they're probably gonna
pillage and if I know anything about
villagers yeah they're my builders or
yeah oh I get it
oh it's three builders and they get
expended every time they build oh that's
good that's a good way to do it that is
a good way to I like that I like that
that is good also fortifying their
doesn't do me any good because they are
major victory there they're just firing
arrows in our thing it is not that life
assure is distasteful to me but life at
sea is better
nice yeah I like that okay so you try to
go there where's my Barbies my bar bows
are by Bobo's okay I can hit those guys
but then I would be defenseless to those
guys they're gonna they're gonna trance
me anyway oh boy oh boy oh boy I'm in a
bit of trouble I didn't make enough but
I thought I was alone on this island and
that was my mistake because apparently
as the opposite of true alright so I'm
pretty close but this is this quick
stuff I just need to do this because I
need to get this done please tell me up
skill without imagination is
craftsmanship and gives us many useful
objects such as wickerwork picnic basket
thanks Tom Stoppard okay
ah yes okay all right oh I love is nice
okay all right so anyway I'm in a bit of
a conundrum but I'm all out of time for
this episode so I'm an end this here I'm
gonna play this a little more just
because I'm enjoying myself and I'm
really having a good time with this I
love civilization I really do it's a
great game and I'm not playing it very
strategically here and I'm not playing
it very well but hopefully I can survive
and hopefully Gandhi is not waiting for
me over on the horizon so in the next
episode we'll see what other people are
on this world is such as me also with me
and do the thing and also we'll see if I
even survive this barbarian raid which I
probably won't because I'm amazing and
great so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye
[Music]